new at 11 an effort to better serve
domestic violence survivors across our
state it's a national report release
this month showing the number one need
in Nevada is emergency housing for
someone escaping an abusive situation
Sasha Loftus looked into this story
joining us now live with more on local
efforts Sasha to help out
Ryan Nevada has
one in the entire country that's why the
Advocates we spoke with are doing what
they can to change that narrative
it's not a simple thing Metro Sheriff
Kevin mcmahill one of several speaking
on the issue of domestic violence during
a town hall we continue to have a number
of those types of innovative
relationships it was the top cause of
homicides in their jurisdiction last
year
victims that are normal victims listen
there's there's children involved the
national network to end domestic
violence released its annual report on
Nevada this month and many statistics
stand out what we know is as a state we
have work to do mainly a lack of housing
resources Liz ortenberger with safeness
says this especially hits home for those
living under the poverty line many times
the reason a Survivor is going back is
because my choice is to leave my abuser
and experience homelessness or stay with
my abuser she says the solution doesn't
just start with temporary resources but
but socioeconomic stability when a
survivor of domestic violence has
Financial Independence even if they
choose to go back to that abuser that
relationship changes dramatically their
organization working with others like
these officers to keep as many as they
can safe the opportunity to sort of
disrupt that cycle of violence that we
see
now the good news that study showed that
291 people were able to find emergency
housing when escaping at domestic
violence situation last year now if you
need help safenest does have a 24-hour
hotline you see the number on your
screen it is
702-646-4981 reporting live tonight
Sasha Loftus 8 news now be